il est une fleur qui a su très tôt
attirer l'œil avisé des botanistes
cultivé depuis l'Antiquité en Égypte et
en Asie du Sud-Est elle fut introduite
en Europe dès le 12e
siècle
l'île de la Réunion possède en son sein
trois hibiscus
méconnus le full sapate marron pousse
encore ça et là de 0 à 1200 m d'altitude
c'est un petit arbre qui peut atteindre
8 m de haut les feuilles juvéniles sont
très différentes des feuilles adultes on
dit que la plante est
hétérophile en effet les feuilles des
jeunes pouss sont en forme de pâte de
poule alors que les feuilles adultes
sont pleines et entières arrondi pointu
à l'extrémité et dentelé
légèrement cette différence permet
peut-être aux jeunes PL de mieux
résister aux périodes sèches ou encore
de passer inaperçu auprès des prédateurs
directs que pouvaient représenter les
tortues peu d'arbres ont la chance à la
réunion de posséder des fleurs de taille
conséquente ils se contentent en général
de privilégier la quantité attirant un
grand nombre d'insectes en même temps
sur une espèce
donnée pourtant le sa pte marron a
développé une stratégie un peu
différente ces magnifiques fleurs se
déploient les unes après les autres
attirant autant les insectes que les
oiseaux les mouches se régalent des
grains de pollen qui garnissent les
éthamines le nectar sucré contenu dans
chaque fleur attire plutôt les abeilles
et les oiseaux
les oiseaux verts et les merles passent
furtivement d'une fleur à une autre se
camouflant dans la
végétation l'hibiscus borianus est très
prolifique en grain et chaque fleur va
donner naissance à un petit fruit vert
qui grossit rapidement
une fois tombé au sol les graines
germent abondamment assurant ainsi la
pérenité de
l'espèce l'ancêtre du marron a su
trouver le chemin à travers les océans
pour s'installer sur cette nouvelle
terre afin d'y fonder une nouvelle
espèce